>> Neil: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS FOND
OF CALLING OUT THE MEDIA ON FAKE
NEWS.
BUT IS HE THE ONE GIVING THEM
REAL AMMUNITION?
MAYBE NOT INTENTIONALLY.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT, MR. PRESIDENT AND SAY NOT
DELIBERATELY.
BUT CONSISTENTLY.
SO LET ME BE CLEAR,
MR. PRESIDENT.
HOW CAN YOU DRAIN THE SWAMP IF
YOU'RE THE ONE THAT KEEPS
MUDDYING THE WATERS?
YOU DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE
$130,000 PAYMENT TO A PORN STAR
TILL YOU DID.
YOU ACKNOWLEDGED TODAY YOU WERE
THE GUY BEHIND THE RETAINER
PAYMENT THAT TOOK CARE OF THIS.
YOU INSIST THAT MONEY FROM THE
CAMPAIGN OR CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS PLAYED NO ROLE IN
THIS TRANSACTION.
OF THAT YOU'RE SURE.
THE THING IS, NOT 24 HOURS AGO,
SIR, YOU COULDN'T RECALL ANY OF
THIS.
YOU SEEM VERY SURE.
I'M NOT SAYING YOU'RE A LIAR.
YOU'RE A PRESIDENT, YOU'RE BUSY.
I'M HAVING A DEVIL OF A TIME
FIGURING OUT WHICH NEWS IS FAKE.
YOUR OWN WORDS GAVE ME LOTS OF
PAUSE.
LIKE THE TIME YOU SAID THE
RUSSIANS DIDN'T INTERFERE IN THE
2016 ELECTIONS UNTIL THE
REPUBLICANS HAD TO REMIND YOU
THEY DID.
MONTHS LATER, YOU SAID, WELL, I
NEVER SAID THAT RUSSIA DIDN'T
MEDDLE IN THE ELECTION WHEN IN
FACT YOU HAD A LOT.
NONE OF THIS MAKES ME A NEVER
TRUMPER.
JUST CONFUSED.
WHEN YOU CLAIMS YOUR TAX CUT WAS
IN THE BIGGEST IN HISTORY WHEN
IT WASN'T.
OR THAT YOUR JOB ISN'T THAT BAD
RELATIVE TO OTHER PRESIDENTS.
THEY'RE WORSE THAN MOST
PRESIDENTS AT THIS STAGE.
THAT CAN CHANGE, BUT WHAT IS
WEIRD, THE PATTERN DOES NOT.
LIKE THE TIME YOU SAY RUMORS OF
REX TILLERSON'S DEPARTURE AT THE
STATEMENT DEPARTMENT WERE FALSE
UNTIL THEY WEREN'T.
OR YOUR FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF,
LANCE PRIEBUS WASN'T GOING
ANYWHERE UNTIL HE WAS.
OUR YOUR ECONOMIC ADVISER, GARY
COHN, WAS DOING A GREAT JOB
UNTIL HE WASN'T.
WHEN YOU LOVE STEVE BANNON UNTIL
YOU DIDN'T.
SWORE BY JEFF SESSIONS UNTIL YOU
SWORE AT HIM.
HAD YOU REMEMBER LEGAL TEAM
LOCKED IN PLACE UNTIL IT WAS
PRESIDENT.
DENIED REPORTS THAT YOU WERE
EVER THINKING ABOUT FIRING
ROBERT MUELLER EVEN AS YOU NOW
THREAT TO GET INVOLVED AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
NOBODY OF THIS MAKES YOU EVIL.
I'M SURE YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WHY
EVEN YOUR FRIENDS SAY THESE
INCONSISTENCIES DON'T MAKE YOU
LOOK GOOD OR DO ANYTHING TO HELP
ADVANCE YOUR POLICIES, MANY OF
WHICH ARE VERY GOOD OR THE
PROSPECTS FOR PEACE WITH NORTH
KOREA.
THAT IS REMARKABLY GOOD.
ALL OF THIS STUFF YOU KEEP
BLURTING OUT REMARKABLY BAD
TIMING.
IT'S NOT THAT THESE
EXAGGERATIONS AND OMISSIONS AND
MISSTATEMENTS ARE NOW AND THEN.
MORE LIKE NOW AND THEN SOMETHING
ELSE, ALWAYS SOMETHING ELSE.
LIKE THE TIME YOU CLAIMED YOU
SIGNED MORE BILLS THAN ANY
PRESIDENT EVER, NEGLECTING TO
MENTION THE OTHER FOUR
PRESIDENTS THAT SIGNED MORE.
BRAGGED ABOUT THE NATIONAL DEBT
BEING DOWN AND IT'S SOARED.
IT'S NOT WHAT YOU'RE OMITTING.
IT'S WHAT YOU KEEP STATING AND
NEVER CORRECTING.
LIKE WHEN YOU SAID THERE WAS A
SERIOUS VOTER FRAUD IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE AND THERE WASN'T.
THE SAME ABOUT REPEATED CLAIMS
OF VOTER FRAUD IN VIRGINIA OR
THERE WEREN'T.
MILLIONS OF ILLEGALS VOTED IN
THE LAST ELECTION AND THEY
DIDN'T.
AND WHEN YOU TALKED UP YOUR
MASSIVE LANDSLIDE IN THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE BUT THERE
WASN'T.
AGAIN, NONE OF THIS MAKES WHAT
YOU SAY FAKE.
JUST CALLING OUT THE PRESSER
BEING SO OF A BIT OF A STRETCH.
YOU'RE RIGHT TO SAY SOME OF THEM
ARE OUT TO GET YOU.
OFTENTIMES THEY'RE USING YOUR
OWN WORDS TO BASH YOU.
YOUR BASE PROBABLY MIGHT NOT
CARE.
BUT YOU SHOULD.
I GUESS YOU'RE TOO BUSY DRAINING
THE SWAM TOP STOP AND SMELL THE
STINK YOU'RE CREATING.
THAT'S YOUR STINK.